[Musique]
c'est le célèbre
alcoolisées
totalisé sur les formalités
et
chaumet qui me dit c'est le mot
[Musique]
texas et huit morts dans un concert du
rappeur américain travis cote que s'est
il passé je sais pas ce qui s'est passé
tout ce que je sais c'est que il ya eu
plus de morts à son concert que de gens
qui viennent me voir moi au moins avec
moi vaut être en sécurité
[Musique]
ça me fait sursauter de me voir avec une
gueule pareil sans barbe onic absolument
qu'on trouve un moyen pour défendre
l'art d'être ici ouais je vois je rends
tu vas
bah
ah oui tu es chez toi
les cartes concentre d'essence a été
d'accord
non c'est bon c'est bon ça le faire je
le sais je sais quoi c'est chaud mais
alors il m a dit de faire comme ça oui
d'accord
avec
ce record encore aux aguets
ces histoires de jouets casse
les bagnoles 1001 pattes selon lui
fallut je cherche à le même post quoi si
deux bestioles en anglais ces bornes
life vn à
tarnac ont changé son nom donc changé
son nom
mona
nous il faut qu'on menace
[Musique]
oui